une façon originale de se rafraîchir une
tradition dans le loiret 1937 et des
lyonnais expatriés dans l'agglomération
orléanaise lance les premières joutes
l'union sportive des joutes saint loup
saint j'aimerais voit le jour en 1946 et
connaît un immense succès les kicks
attaques basses et vous j'ai rien du
tout dans l'époque il y avait que les
joutes les gens les berges à salou il
était plein
parce que y'avait pas de sport y avait
pas de télé y avait rien du tout donc il
nous joue tu as beaucoup de titres pour
les licenciés qui en tout perdu après
l'incendié de leur local en 1989 en 2019
le club avait pris en main par les
diamants l'époque
désireux de repartir ensemble
le cobra et ils s'arrêtaient ont été
relativement jeune on arrive à un âge on
le petit groupe qu'on se connaissait on
voulait remonter club on s'était dit que
c'est la bonne période
je m'attendais pas à ce qu'on ait autant
de monde d'autant d'enfants on a plus de
là quasiment 28 petit qui sont qui
viennent s'entraîner et ils sont
actuellement plus de 60 licenciés
en attendant de retrouver peut-être leur
port d'attaché canal salle où il
s'entraîne non loin de là un comble et
organise parfois des démonstrations avec
leurs amis du sud
les promeneurs et curieux peuvent ainsi
découvrir non pas là mais les joutes
pas moins de six méthodes et de nombreux
éléments pour les différencier là le
bateau
ans les tenues de looter les longues
heures de bateau de type de production
alors on peut avoir des moteurs
électriques des moteurs thermiques et
maintenant aussi à la rame en fonction
de la région c'est pas du tout pareil
cécile est six fois championne de france
en joutes parisiennes avec une lance
pour le petit s'entraîne régulièrement
avec ses amis leur est un qui excelle en
la matière n'hésitez pas à aller à leur
rencontre tous les mercredis après midi
et parfois aussi le week end
[Musique]